[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und dunia
Haali schönen guten Abend kriegen wir es
hin dass hier alles noch läuft auch wenn
die Sonne nicht scheint und der Wind
nicht weht neben der Bezahlbarkeit wohl
die ste Frage in Sachen Energiewende
denn zu dieser Wende gehört es nicht nur
die Atommeiler abzuschalten sondern auch
klimaschädliche Kohlemeiler bis 2030 zu
ersetzen bloß wie wo und durch was auf
Antworten wird seit Monaten gewartet
heute gab es sie ausformuliert in der
sogenannten
kraftwerksstrategie ob sie aber auch
ausgeklügelt ist dazuleich ein Gespräch
zu vor der Beitrag von Klaus
brutbeck Zukunft mal anders gedacht
Völklingen im saarand ein Kurs der sie
auf ihren neuen Job vorbereitet in
Zeiten der Energiewende werden sie hier
Kraftwerker ich denke im Gegensatz zur
Automobilindustrie oder andere
Industrien
momentan denke ich dass es ein Job ist
der eher Zukunftsaussichten hat wie
momentan andere Jobs vor d Jahren
dachten sie auch beim Bildungsträger
noch diese Ausbildung könnte auslaufen
von wegen wir sind da auch der
Auffassung es wird ein Mix sein müssen
einfach um die Energiesicherheit auch zu
gewährleisten und dann letztlich auch
die Fachkräfte über die Dauer der Zeit
dann noch
zur Verfügung zu stellen die Dauer der
Zeit Altbach bei Stuttgart in 3 Jahren
soll das bisherige Kohlekraftwerk mit
Gas später mit Wasserstoffstrom
produzieren ein Symbol für den Wandel in
kürzester Zeit will die Bundesregierung
etwa 20 wasserstofffähige Gaskraftwerke
mit einer Kapazität von 10 Gigawatt
errichten lassen kosten ungefähr 16
Milliarden verteilt auf 20
Jahre das ist ein wichtiger ein
bedeutsamer Schritt das Stromsystem wird
im Jahr 2030 etwa zu 80% mit
erneuerbaren Energien also Wind und
sonneenenergie gefahren werden aber
nicht immer scheint die Sonne und nicht
immer wir der Wind und die Konsequenz
ist wir brauchen grundlastfähige
Kraftwerke und das ist das was die
kraftwerkstrategie gewährleisten soll
dass wir die Technik verfügbar haben
Erfahrung gesammelt haben haben und
natürlich auch Schritte jetzt schon zur
dekarbonisierung gehen ich bin sehr
zufrieden mit der Lösung denn die Lösung
beinhaltet einen kapazitätsmechanismus
das heißt ein günstigen Zubau von
Kraftwerkskapazitäten jetzt muss es
schnell in die Umsetzung gehen damit wir
saubere und sichere Energieversorgung
auch im Winter haben statt wie bisher
nur für die Produktion von Strom sollen
die Betreiber künftig durch diesen
kapazitätsmechanismus auch dafür bezahlt
werden Kraftwerke für den Bedarfsfall
vorzuhalten der Union ist das zu wage
alle Fragen sind offen wir wissen nicht
wann ausgeschrieben wird wie
ausgeschrieben wird wie das bezahlt wird
und damit gibt's keine Verlässlichkeit
Netzbetreiber und Stromversorger aber
begrüßen die kraftwerksstrategie das ist
ein sehr wichtiger Schritt in die
richtige Richtung viele Sachen werden
geregelt wie z.B dass eine Unterstützung
werden gibt für wasserstofffähige
Gaskraftwerke die Leistung wird gegeben
und auch einige Maßen der der Zeitplan
so dürften auch sie das Sehen neue
Technik statt Alter Kohle es hat
Perspektive aber ergibt das ganze auch
Sinn Fragen dazu jetzt an die
energieökonomin Claudia kämfert die die
Abteilung Energie Verkehr und Umwelt am
Deutschen Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung leitet und damit
einen schönen guten Abend Frau kämfert
guten Abend Frau Ziele und Wege sein
formuliert heißt es jetzt ist das denn
wirklich der große W
ich sehe es nicht wirklich als großen
Wurf man verlängert hier die fossilen
Geschäftsmodelle insbesondere
Gaskraftwerke für die man ohnehin auch
Förderung hätte wenn man sie denn
fördern wollte über
kraftwerksrerven oder auch
netzreserven und die Möglichkeit hätte
man sowieso
kraftwerärmekopplungsförderung also da
hätte es genügend Möglichkeiten gegeben
es effizienter zu machen vor allen
Dingen auch preiswerter und
offensichtlich auch ökologischer aber
warum wird dann das ganze überhaupt
gemacht die Bundesregierung geht ja
hoffentlich nicht absichtlich den aus
ihrer Sicht falschen Weg ja man denkt
nicht wirklich vom Ende her sondern man
denkt im jetzigen System und verlängert
alles immer so lang wie es möglich ist
das ist auch verständlich weil fossile
Gaskonzerne die wollen ihre
Geschäftsmodelle möglichst lange
betreiben und der Kraftwerkspark muss
aber umstrukturiert werden wir wollen ja
die Energiewende erreichen mit mehr
erneuerbare Energien und damit gilt es
auch diese Transformation voranzubringen
und da gilt es auch wirklich vom Ende
her zu denken und das klappt leider
bisher nicht so auch weil sie nicht für
möglich halten dass wir so viel grünen
Wasserstoff produzieren ja der grüne
Wasserstoff steht ja aktuell noch gar
nicht zur Verfügung wir produzieren
überhaupt gar keinen grünen Wasserstoff
können ihn auch nicht importieren es
gibt ja keine ausreichende Infrastruktur
wir müssten fünfm so viel erneuerbare
Energien ausbauen um wirklich grün
Wasserstoff in ausreichend Mengen
herzustellen da ist man weit von
entfernt das heißt man beginnt jetzt
erstmal die fossilen Erdgaskraftwerke zu
fördern und ich fürchte einfach dass sie
auch sehr lange weiterlaufen werden weil
man eben diesen Umstieg erst viel später
wenn überhaupt macht aber grundlastfähig
wären wir dann ja die Gaskraftwerke sind
grundsätzlich Spitzenlast Kraftwerke das
heißt sie sind nur dann im Einsatz wenn
wirklich kein Wind oder keine Sonne da
ist und sie schnell zugeschaltet werden
können deswegen sind sie ja auch so
teuer und kommen selten zum Einsatz das
heißt wir brauchen wirklich ein
grundlassfähiges Energiesystem als
Ganzes mit mehr erneuerbare Energien
ganz viel erneuerbare Energien
dezentrale Verteilnetze sind wichtig
Energie und lmanagement aber auch
zukünftig mehr speichern also für die
Energiewende wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe hilft es zwar aber nicht wenn
wir die Klimaziele erreichen wollen wie
sieht es denn dann mit den Kosten aus
ist da Besserung in Sicht also wird
Energie für bürg und auch für die
Wirtschaft wieder günstiger nein leider
nicht man wäht ja hier den
kostenintensivsten Weg indem man erstmal
fossile Erdgaskraftwerke subventioniert
die man eigentlich gar nicht am Markt
subventionieren müsste dann der
Wasserstoff der ist auch teuer und all
das wird dann letztendlich die Kosten
für die VerbraucherInnen auch weiter in
die Höhe treiben dabei gäbe es deutlich
preiswertere Möglichkeiten nämlich indem
man mehr auf Effizienz setzt indem man
mehr Strom und Energie einspart aber
indem man vor allen Dingen mehr
erneuerbare Energien nutzt okay also sie
kritisieren dass es subventioniert wird
und bezweifeln auch dass es ausreichend
und Zeit na grün Wasserstoff gibt und
einiges mehr was ist ihre Alternative
oder bzw warum wird das nicht gemacht
was sie jetzt gerade schon angedeutet
haben ja es klingt immer verlockend dass
man jetzt erstmal nur Kraftwerke fördert
das kennen wir auch aus der
Vergangenheit aber dann bleiben sie ewig
lange noch im Einsatz und das behindert
die Energiewende die Alternativen sind
die erneuerbaren Energien mit mehr mehr
erneuerbare Energien als heute es gibt
auch nachhaltige Biomasse beispielsweise
die zum Einsatz kommen kann Wind und
Solar sowieso aber in der Kombination
eben mit flexibilitäten das heißt
effektiven Energie und Lastmanagement
also auf dezentraler Ebene wirklich
Lösungen finden dann kann es auch und
das ist der Weg dahin zu einem
effizienten Energiesystem kommen sagt
die energieökonomin Claudia kämfert
vielen Dank fürs Gespräch ich danke
Ihnen und das haben wir kurz vor vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet es scheint ein
Ruck durch dieses Land zu gehen einer
der nicht nachlässt denn seit Wochen
gehen nun mehr Menschen in Nordost
Südwest auf dem Land und in den Städten
auf die Straße um für Demokratie und für
Pluralität und gegen Rechtsextremismus
und gegen Faschismus zu demonstrieren
die Zusammenkünfte sind in der Regel
organisiert von Verbänden von der
Zivilgesellschaft unter die sich aber
natürlich auch Politiker mischen sich
diesem wirgefühl anzuschließen ist halt
einfach nur das reicht nicht es reicht
den Vertretern von diversen Verbänden
nicht sie wollen wissen was das wir
stehen fest an ihrer Seite des Kanzlers
Wert ist Ines
Trams die Demonstrationen sie gehen auch
an diesem Montag weiter 480 000 waren am
Wochenende bundesweit gegen
Rechtsradikalismus auf der Straße heute
nun Fr amain von ganzen Herzen bin ich
heute hier gekommen für Demokratie
gchtigkeit gegen Rassismus ich freue
mich über die Demokratiebewegung die
dieser Spaltung dieser Gesellschaft
Einhalt gebietet und ich wünsche mir
dass die lange durchhält sehr wachsam
bleibt von der Politik wünsche mir auch
etwas mehr Unterstützung diese
Unterstützung will Kanzler Scholz heute
geben zumindest symbolhaft Treffen mit
Vertretern von migrantenverbänden
zuhören will er und Sicherheit in einer
Zeit großer Verunsicherung für
Einwanderer rassistische Ideologie habe
keinen Platz in Deutschland wir stehen
fest an ihrer Seite wir lassen nicht zu
dass Extremismus und Intoleranz unsere
Gesellschaft Spalten alle 84 Millionen
Bürger und Bürger in unserem Land haben
die gleichen Rechte alle verdienen
Respekt und darum geht's die Migranten
berichten dem Kanzler von ihren
alltäglichen Erfahrungen mit Ismus und
Rassismus täglich unter Generalverdacht
gestellt zu werden immer wieder auch
bespuckt zu werden wir leben
verschiedene Formen von Rassismus
Menschen wurde gespuckt und das ist auch
nicht unnormal das ist was alltägliche
Leben von viele Menschen die wie ich
hier in Deutschland leben und das wollen
wir nicht zugucken am wohnungsmark in
der Schule also das Gefühl als
migrantisch gelesene Mensch oder
muslimisch gelesene Mensch ständig
erklären zu müssen
was man alles nicht ist also dass du
nicht antisemitisch bist dass du nicht
islamistisch bist und so weiter said
Hashemi überlebte das rassistische
Attentat von Hanau vor knapp vier Jahren
schwer verletzt er verlor seinen kleinen
Bruder heute fragt er sich haben wir
noch eine Zukunft in diesem Land die
aktuellen Demonstrationen für ihn ein
Zeichen der
Wertschätzung das was die Menschen jetzt
gerade machen nämlich dass sie auf die
Straße gehen und für eine vielfältige
Gesellschaft kämpfen das ist äh so ein
starkes Zeichen und diesen Spielball hat
die Gesellschaft jetzt an die Politik
weitergegeben und nun sind sie an der
Reihe die Politik in Berlin sandte heute
Worte der Versicherung und Unterstützung
nicht weniger aber auch nicht mehr die
Menschen auf der Straße wie hier in
Frankfurt warten allerdings weiter auf
Taten Gesicht zeigen seine Stimme
erheben Aufforderungen die sich ja
schnell sagen lassen Aufforderungen die
sich in einer großen Menschenmenge in
der man als Individuum eher untergeht
auch relativ ungefährlich umsetzen
lassen doch was wenn man in einer
kleineren Gruppe unterwegs ist was
letzen Freitag ab wenn Fotos von ihnen
gemacht werden die dann z.B in
rechtsextrem oder islamistischen
chatgruppen verteilt werden oder was
wenn sie bekannt sind und sie jemand auf
der Straße erkennt und attackiert genau
das ist einem jüdischen Studenten in
Berlin passiert er wurde von einem
komelitonen angegriffen und
krankenhausreif geschlagen wohl weil er
Jude ist Christ
leler letzten Freitagabend in Berlin
Mitte am Rosentaler Platz ein Hotspot
des Berliner Nachtlebens in einer B wird
der jüdische Fu Student LAH Shapira von
einem Mitstudenten erkannt als der
30jährige chapira mit seiner Begleitung
das Lokal verlässt attackiert ein
23-jähriger Palästinenser seinen
komeliton
er hat mir plötzlich einen fausthb von
der Seite gegeben und dann noch einen
dann habe ich das Gleichgewicht verloren
ich habe versucht aufzustehen und dann
hat er mir ins Gesicht
getreten der Barbesuch endet in der
charit Diagnose Knochenbrüche im Gesicht
Folge ein Schock auch bei der
Begleiterin nicht mehr sicher zu
sein ich war schockiert es war
furchtbar alles so schnell ich konnte es
kaum verstehen ich schrie und versuchte
sie zu trennen aber leider ohne Erfolg
und plötzlich blutet l und liegt auf dem
Boden und dieser Typ ist einfach
weggeranntter und Opfer kennen sich
beide studieren an der FU der 23-Jährige
Palästinenser kann ermittelt werden sein
Smartphone wird beschlagnaht der
Staatsschutz
ermittelt seit dem 7 Oktober eskalieren
die Proteste gegen Israels Krieg im Gaza
proalästinensische Gruppen fühlen sich
ausgegrenzt und besetzen einen hörsal
sie sprechen Israel das Existenzrecht ab
und fordern ein freies
Palästina l Shapira hier im Bild hält
mit einigen jüdischen Mitstudierenden
dagegen es wird gerangelt und gestritten
die Stimmung ist aufgeheizt erst als die
Polizei räumt beruhigen sich die
Gemüter die Situation erschreckt
natürlich ein leider wurden aus den
Worten die schon seit Wochen in der FU
geäußert worden sind seitens der
extremistischen Studenten jetzt nun
Taten und die Situation beängstigt ein
und beängstigt natürlich nicht nur mich
sondern auch viele weitere Studenten
jüdisch sowie nicht jüdisch die sich
generell engagieren weil man sich jetzt
auch fragt ist man sicher wenn man
beispielsweise abends einfach nur
entspannt in eine Bar geht die
Universitätsleitung verurteilt die Tat
auf das Schärfste ein Interview gibt es
nicht dafür folgende
Erklärung wenn sich bestätigt dass der
Täter Student der Freien Universität ist
wird die Hochschule gegebenenfalls ein
Verbot
durchsetzen besonders tragisch l
schapiras Großvater war bei Olympia 72
in München eines der Opfer er wurde beim
Massaker an israelischen Sportlern durch
die Terrororganisation schwarzer
September
ermordet wird jetzt der Nahostkonflikt
wieder auf deutschenem Boden
ausgetragen nötig ist ist eine starker
Rückhalt der
Zivilgesellschaft das muss das ist nicht
nur einmalig das muss das ist eigentlich
ttäglich das ist eben kein wegschauen
sondern ein intervenieren ein Eingreifen
das notwendig ist am kommenden
Donnerstag wird an der Freien
Universität wieder demonstriert für
palästiner aber hoffentlich ohne weitere
Eskalation was macht man wenn eine
Beziehung ruckelt oder gar eingeschlafen
ist man fährt ohne Umwege hin setzt
seinen ganzen Scharm ein und überzeugt
mit schönen Worten und die andere Seite
die den roten Teppich aus fährt ganz
groß auf und zeigt sich von seiner
besten Seite so ungefähr kann man sich
heute das Treffen zwischen Bundeskanzler
Scholz und dem neuen französischen
premier vorstellen immerhin hat Gabriel
atall im Gegensatz zu seinen zwei
Vorgängern Berlin mit seinem
Antrittsbesuch nicht warten lassen doch
wer ist denn eigentlich dieser
34jähriger Atal der politisch einen
rasanten Aufstieg hinlegt Thomas
beide jung ist er aber er pflegt eine
Tradition die ersten Schritte auf dem
internationalen Parkett führen
französische Amtsträger in der Regel
nach Deutschland so auch Gabriel Atal
für diplomatische Höflichkeiten bleibt
wenig Zeit auf die Frage was er von den
Protesten in Deutschland gegen die AFD
halte offenbart Atal was ihn um und
antreibt die Parteien der extremen
Rechten die in Europa auf dem Vormarsch
sind haben eines gemeinsam sie wollen
Europa abbauen wir hier wollen Europa
weiter
Atal hat keine Schonfrist in der
Europapolitik nicht und auch nicht zu
Hause Stunden vor dem Besuch in Berlin
musste er ein Misstrauensvotum im
Parlament überstehen eingebracht von der
Linken sie haben versucht meine
Regierung zu stürzen das hindert mich
weder in meinem Willen zu handeln noch
in meiner Absicht zum
Dialog seit Beginn seiner Amtszeit ist
Atal im krisenmodus als die Bauern auf
die Straße ziehen führt er die
Verhandlungen selbst
um voranzukommen müssen wir unsere
Haltung ändern Sie erwarten und das ist
normal konkrete Maßnahmen wir haben sie
beschlossen und gesagt das ist nur der
Anfang wir machen Tag für Tag und Woche
für Woche
weitersreierung kommt den Bauern weit
entgegen die ziehen am Wochenende ab dem
Präsidenten Probleme abnehmen das ist
eine der Aufgaben des
34jährigen istronist der ersten Stunde
ein Gefolgsmann Parteisprecher stat
Minister auch als Premier kennt er nur
den
Vorwärtsgang konfrontieren um
voranzukommen bei den wirtschaftlichen
klimatischen demografischen und
geopolitischen Veränderungen wir stoppen
niemals seine Amtsvorgängerin Elisabeth
born kam von den Sozialisten in macrons
Lager Atal auch aber er ist flexibler
und ändert den Kurs mehr Verantwortung
und Freiheit für den Einzelnen strengere
Regeln für Schüler und
sozialhilfeempfängeral soll den
Vormarsch der extremen Rechten und
Marine Le Pen
stoppen für macron geht es vor allem um
die Europawahlen dafür formt er diese
Regierung die strukturelle
Herausforderung seiner Amtszeit besteht
aber weiter darin Gesetze
durchzubringen und das bleibt schwer
ohne eigene Mehrheit im Parlament neuer
premier hin oder her einst war er
derjenige der Frankreichs politische
Landschaft umwälzte jetzt braucht
Emmanuel macron einen Jugendlichen
Regierungschef um neuen Schwung zu
entfachen der anfangszauber verfliegt
schnell in der französischen
Politik nicht nur dort mehr zu den
deutsch-französischen Beziehungen später
in unserem heute journal
Update und wir machen jetzt weiter mit
Nachrichten Hanna und bleiben dabei
quasi auf dem Boden ja sogar im wahsten
Sinne des Wortes die Passagiere der
lufthanser müssen sich ab Mittwoch auf
Flugausfälle und Verspätungen einstellen
die Gewerkschaft werdi hat das
Bodenpersonal an den Flughäfen Frankfurt
München Hamburg Berlin und Düsseldorf zu
einem 27stündigen Warnstreik aufgerufen
mehr als 100.000 Passagiere dürften laut
lufthanser davon betroffen sein Grund
sind die festgefahrenen
Tarifverhandlungen werdi fordert für das
Bodenpersonal eine Gehaltserhöhung von
12,5% bei einer Laufzeit von 12
Monaten in der Debatte um Entlastungen
für die deutsche Wirtschaft herrscht in
der Ampelkoalition weiter Uneinigkeit
eine von Fin Minister Lindner
vorgeschlagene Abschaffung des
Solidaritätszuschlags für Unternehmen
stieß bei den Koalitionspartnern heute
auf Ablehnung spdchefin eskin sieht vor
allem Probleme bei der Finanzierbarkeit
es gehe dabei um 30 Milliarden Euro die
dann im Bundeshaushalt fehlen würden
sagte esken auch grünen Vorsitzende lang
lehnte den Vorstoß
ab Verteidigungsminister Pistorius hat
der Regierung im Kosovo nach den
Spannungen mit Serbien weitere
militärische unterstü stüung
Deutschlands zugesichert die Bundeswehr
liege mit Plänen für die Entsendung
zusätzlicher Soldaten im Zeitplan sagte
der SPD Politiker bei einem Treffen mit
Präsidentin Osmani derzeit sind im
Kosovo etwa 90 Bundeswehrsoldaten im
Einsatz von April an sollen es rund 150
mehr sein Kosovo und Serbien rief
Pistorius zu Dialog und Deeskalation
auf nach dem Angriff auf einen
usmitärstüz Punkt in Jordanien ist
erneut ein eine US-Basis angegriffen
worden dieses Mal in Syrien dabei sollen
sieben Kämpfer der syrischen
demokratischen Kräfte getötet worden
sein verantwortlich sein proiranische
Milizen erklärte die syrische
Beobachtungsstelle für Menschenrechte
die Attacke sei eine Reaktion auf die
usvergeltungsschläge in Syrien und im
Irak bei dem Angriff auf die
us-mitärbasis in Jordanien vor knapp
einer Woche war war dre US-Soldaten
getötet
worden seit mehr als 9 Jahren herrscht
im Grunde fast durchgängig Bürgerkrieg
im Jemen es geht um politische Macht und
den Zugang zu Ressourcen für die
Menschen dagegen geht es ums nackte
Überleben über 17 Millionen leiden
Hunger über 40% so die Schätzungen
sollen arbeitslos sein interessiert hat
das in all den Jahren selten
irgendjemanden seit die H aber Schiffe
angreifen und internationale
Handelsrouten stören ist das Land medial
wieder präsent die Menschen aber
weiterhin nicht Gine über das Armenhaus
der arabischen Welt wie der Jemen schon
vor dem Bürgerkrieg bezeichnet wurde und
die schwierige Arbeit der
Hilfsorganisationen dieser Moment wenn
Sie das pausenbrut Aufmachen für 11000
Schüler in jeemens Hauptstadt ist er der
schönste des Vormittags den Frühstück
müssten viele den Schulbesuch aufgeben
und arbeiten gehen der Unternehmer der
diese pausenbrute organisiert versorgte
früher zetausende Schüler mehr bis die
hies sein Projekt stoppten denn nur die
hies bestimmen wer Hilfe bekommt nur die
hthis verteilen die
Hilfe es ist echt kompliziert es gibt
viele Probleme die uns immer wieder
zurückdräen aber wir geben nicht
auf mehr dar nicht sagen denn humanitäre
Helfer im huthi Gebiet sind stets in
Lebensgefahr das un
Welternährungsprogramm das diese
Pausenbrote finanziert hat den größten
Teil seiner Hilfe im huig Gebiet vorerst
ausgesetzt sie sind die Betroffenen in
einem der größten Vertriebenen Lager im
Nordjemen ist die Stimmung spürbar
gereizt nicht nur fällt das
internationale Spendenaufkommen Jahr für
Jahr kleiner aus seit 5 Monaten kam hier
gar NS
an jetzt bekommen wir nicht einmal mehr
die Nahrungsmittelhilfen aus dem Ausland
wir haben kein Essen kein Wasser kein
Haus nur den kalten Erdboden es gibt
keine Hoffnung für unsere
Kinder die UN werfen den hthis vor
internationale Hilfe nur an ihre
politischen Günstlinge zu verteilen
nicht an die Bedürftigsten mehr noch h
haben Dutzende humanitäre Helfer
entführt zuletzt Star ein Mitarbeiter
von unter Folter in einem h
Gefängnis die Jemeniten wollen dass die
internationale Gemeinschaft die his zur
Verantwortung zieht für die Manipulation
die Ausbeutung die Verhinderung
internationaler
Hilfe wir Menschenrechtler sehen wie
dadurch die his die Bevölkerung als
Geiseln
halten eine Klinik für terrte Kinder im
H Gebiet ohne die Hilfsorganisation
Ärzte ohne Grenzen wäre hier überhaupt
keine Versorgung für Sie möglich immer
mehr Fälle würden gerade eingeliefert
berichten
Ärzte der Schmerz mit dem wir leben ist
unbeschreibbar Schmerz Angst Trauer die
Folgen von Kriegen und Hungersnot die
Mehrheit im Land ist mit Hunger
konfrontiert je mehr Hunger mehr die
Propaganda der Bevölkerung weismchen
dass die internationale Gemeinschaft den
Jemen damit bestrafen
will und wir machen hier weiter mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft Hanner ja
und da geht es heute ums E-Auto das Ziel
ist klar mehr daavollen sollen auf die
Straßen doch die neuesten Zahlen des
Kraftfahrt buundesamts für Januar zeigen
es haakt im Getriebe im Vergleich zum
Vormonat sind die Neuzulassungen bei den
Elektroautos um rund
59% eingebrochen eine Zahl Frank betmann
die aufhorchen lässt womit ist das zu
erklären na vor allem mit dem
plötzlichen Stopp der staatlichen
Förderung im Dezember quasi über Nacht
einige Autohersteller sprangen zwar ein
übernahmen die Umweltprämie insgesamt
aber bedeutete das für den Absatz von
Elektroautos einen kräftigen Dämpfer
auch schon im Januar von den über 213
000 Fahrzeugen waren nämlich knapp 82
000 Benziner gefolgt von Neuwagen mit
Hybridantrieb dann kommen die Diesel und
dann erst mit gut 22 000 Stück die
reinen Elektroautos es sieht ganz
einfach danach aus als würde der kurze
elektroautoboom hier zuulande schon
wieder zu Ende sein was bedeutet das
denn für die deutsche Autoindustrie ja
die hat damit ein Problem zum einen
haben sich die deutschen Autobauer der
Elektromobilität verschrieben
Deutschland ist das wissen längst nicht
alle nach China einer der größten
Produktionsstandorte für E-Autos die
Produktion soll weiter deutlich
hochgefahren werden ein Großteil der
Elektrofahrzeuge wird längst ins Ausland
verkauft da läuft es derzeit auch ganz
gut die Frage ist allerdings wie lange
noch es droht ein weltweiter Preiskampf
für die deutschen Hersteller die sind da
nicht gut aufgestellt man fertige mit zu
hohen Kosten heißt es und da schmerzt es
dann eben besonders dass man mögliche
Rückschläge auf dem Weltmarkt nicht
kompensieren kann dafür läuft es derzeit
hierzulande einfach zu schlecht vielen
Dank Frank für diese
Einschätzungen die staatenorganisation
OECD hat ihre Wachstumsprognose für die
deutsche Wirtschaft für das aktuelle
Jahr halbiert erwartet wird ein Zuwachs
von
0,3% im November wurden noch 0,6%
prognostiziert andere Industrienationen
stehen dagegen deutlich besser da so hob
die OECD ihre Wachstumsprognose für die
USA an von 1,5 auf
2,1%. der britische König Charles II ist
an Krebs erkrankt das teilte der
Buckingham Palast am Abend mit welche
genaue Form von Krebs ist bisher nicht
bekannt nach Angaben des Palasts haben
habe Charles bereits mit der Behandlung
begonnen und werde auf Anraten der Ärzte
öffentliche Auftritte verschieben die
Staatsgeschäfte werde er jedoch
weiterführen die Bürger von Paris haben
entschieden in der französischen
Hauptstadt wird das Parken im
öffentlichen Raum für Besucher mit SUVs
und anderen schweren Autos bald deutlich
teurer ab September sollen die
Parkgebühren für Sie verdreifacht werden
von 6 € auf 18 € pro Stunde das ist das
Ergebnis einer Bürgerbefragung an der
sich gestern knapp 6% der Pariser
Beteiligten die Stadt erhofft sich
dadurch bessere Luft und mehr
Verkehrssicherheit Anwohner sind nicht
betroffen in Los Angeles sind zum 66 mal
die wohl wichtigsten Musikpreise der
Welt verliehen orden die Grammys und
dabei haben weibliche Künstlerinnen klar
dominiert Sängerin Miley Cyrus wurde
zweifach ausgezeichnet bil eilish
erhielt mit ihrem Lied what was I made
for unter anderem den Grammy für den
Song des Jahres tayor Swift schaffte es
sogar Grammy Geschichte zu schreiben sie
erhielt den Preis für das Album des
Jahres zum vierten Mal und damit so oft
wie niemand
zuvor ein persönliches Highlight chatman
mit fast car sie hat seit fast 10 Jahren
nicht mehr live im Fernsehen gesungen
das war schön mal zu sehen so lange
müssen wir heute aufs heute journal
Update nicht warten NAS g mir meldet
sich hier gegen 23:40 Uhr das war's von
uns machen sie es gut wo immer sie sind
[Musik]
tschüss
guten Abend das wird eine Woche der
wettergegensätze das macht sich
bemerkbar durch dieses Tief Olga z.B das
sehr viel Wind mitbringt und auch Regen
nach Norddeutschland bis morgen Abend
wird dieses Tief das Baltikum erreicht
haben das hochfrank kennen wir noch vom
Wochenende das ist gut für Sonnenschein
in Süddeutschland jetzt in der Nacht
sinken die Temperaturen am Alpenrand auf
2 oder 1° deutlich milder bleibt die
Nacht am niederrehein mit 9° den auch in
der Nacht ziehen über Norddeutschland
die Regenwolken hinweg bei
westsüdwestwind im Süden ist es dagegen
klar diese Wetter Zweiteilung haben wir
auch morgen über Tag also im Süden
scheint wieder strahlend die Sonne sonst
gibt's viele Wolken und Regen zieht über
Norddeutschland bei einem sehr kräftigen
Wind aus westsüdwestlichen Richtungen an
der Nordsee kann es auch für sturmböhen
reichen die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen meist bei 7 bis 12° in Ostbayern
wird es mit 15° sogar noch milder und
dann wird es von Norden bis Donner Stag
deutlich kälter dann liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen nur so bei 2 bis 4°
aber diese Kälte kommt nicht weiter nach
Süden voran denn zum Ende der Woche
liegen dann die Höchsttemperaturen
deutschlandweit schon wieder zwischen 5
und 15°. am Mittwoch bedeutet das aber
es kann Schneeregen hier in den
nördlichen Mittelgebirgen geben und am
Donnerstag vielleicht sogar eine
geschlossene Schneedecke in
Norddeutschland machen sie sich auf
Glätte gefasst guten
Abend